is and all the diseases of Despair
whether it's the depression or anxiety
or PTSD or OCD they're all stemming from
the same thing turns out the default
mode Network this the the storytelling
center of the brains the seat of the
soul the ego it turns out that when
we're in a meaning crisis and when we've
lost our way that can be seen in fmri
scans there's a an over determined and
over developed default mode Network a
kind of tightening a kind of like
gnawing like self-defeating thought
pattern fueled Haze people are stuck in
the Rut it's like it's like skiing down
the same steel Roots because because the
because the roots are like they're like
they're like footprinted they're like
they're like cemented you know it's like
going to the grooves we're stuck in
these grooves we're stuck in these
patterns
and it turns out
that dissolving these patterns seems to
be the means to transcend them we